et je lui dis en plus de ça je connais
justin donc à la fin du concert femmes
on va le voir je présente mes justin
bridou justin est ce que vous avez déjà
un mytho pour pécho de baboo gilles
verdez je suis sur le crépuscule s'abat
sur le 15e paris au début des années 90
et à cette époque là comme tous les
soirs je draguais sur minitel 36 15
aline et la web
le gars de façon je voulais dire lui
c'était sûr et sain cst où il terminait
en tout cas en poste où il était en
quartier de sécurité où il a va brasser
électronique un truc voulais c'était sûr
et certain on discute beaucoup
et au bout d'un moment minitel ah oui
oui j'adore être et au bout d'un moment
je me dis il faudra vous taipei clés
doivent se tenir le 5 mai au bout de
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines de
discussions mais dit faudrait qu'on se
rencontre à merde moi mon genre de mec
elle me dit c'est bruce willis où il
avait dit quoi bruce willis web voilà je
dis ça tombe oui c'est bruce tout court
dit ça tombe bien on compare souvent à
lui non ouais donc j'hésite est
important de la rencontre un jour elle
me dit écoute soit on se rend compte
soit on arrête pas normal elle me dit
j'aurais une robe rouge et où je lave
d'anne roumanoff
je la vois arriver elle est magnifique
donc je la vois entré dans le café alors
dit je fais comme ça c'est moi et là
elle me vois je vois dans sa tête que ça
passe pas à l'époque j'avais les cheveux
longs un peu hippie la belle période on
n'y va jamais
hélas elle fonce vers moi dans le café
n'a fait que c'est moi et elle me dit
d'un coup comme ça par mais tu te fous
de ma gueule tu m'avais dit tu
ressemblais à bruce willis et tu
ressembles à francis lalanne
non j'avais rencontré à coiffeur
coloriste permanentiste ces trois ans
avec fabio salsa trois spécialités en
jalles ses coiffeurs ou coloristes ou
permanente isaac argent ça m'intéresse
et et les trois ils étaient les trois
après le fera mais tout de la fois à mes
jeunes et très beau du coup je me dis
peut intéresser en quelle année ça s'est
passé quand le lundi
bon bref c'est benoît n'ont pas du tout
alors benoît n'est pas là pour israël
n'a jamais trahi les terminaux de
bourgogne il a prêté première bourgogne
la gouille la gagnerie laganière j'ai
trop grand même si ils sont fêtés
l'animé rouge de la premier chignon de
bourgogne et rhône et il me dit qu'il
est fan de justin bieber a on va en
parler dans un instant est exactement
donc moi qu'est ce que je fais vim le
lendemain demande à mon assistant
d'appeler le producteur de justin bieber
de dire les mots magiques de leurs mots
et paf d'avoir deux places pour aller
rentrer sur paris
j'estime pour aller voir un concert du
duo exactement ça passe à bercy alors il
ya trois ans de prêts et je lui dis en
plus de ça je connais justin donc à la
fin du concert femmes
on va le voir je présente mes justin
bridou gc la patronne avance même s'il
voulait voir à ce titre ce n'est pas lui
c'est un petit peu avant c'est parce
qu'à l'époque je connaisse pas justin
d'accord que depuis ressemble non non
non non de plus à mon père ça me paraît
donc j'y vais effectivement je sais
qu'on pourra pas le rencontrer tout le
concert il est comme un ouf non on va le
voir à quelle heure en vrac heureux là
et quand le concert se termine jeudi je
suis désolé j'ai reçu un texto
producteurs de justin bieber qui salue
ces matchs de l'en but what dieu mais
est-ce que vous êtes bon tu dis si tu
veux on va à la maison oui et on écoute
de justin bieber non bah ouais et le
coin les marchés en fait ce soir et
c'est du rêve au cauchemar
il est venu à la maison et le reste je
vous laisse je rêvais pas écouté j'ai
envie de vous dire que lui
faites vous plaisir j'étais en corse
balaj et en corse en boîte de nuit il y
avait de très jolies jeunes filles avec
quatre jeunes filles et je voulais
absolument me rapprocher d'elle jeudi à
écouter où se trouve que j'ai un bateau
dans le port magnifique sur mon père il
fait 45 m une fois bien jean pierre
castaldi
ça commençait mal mais les connais toi
toi répond lui dire vous avez le fort
boyard et donc biba sortons la boîte de
nuit partons sur le bateau de mon père
est évidemment mon père n'a pas de
bateau de 45 qu'il avait eue ici
un tout petit bateau de sept mètres de
long donc c'est vraiment tout du bateau
je pars sur le port je prends un ponton
que je pense était bonne celui de mon
père est en fait c'est le ponton des
énormes bateaux well as plus on avance
plus les bateaux sont longs et là les
filles se rapproche de moi et
honnêtement on avance elle se rapproche
et et hop elle me faisait un énorme pas
l'eau non sans qu'on allait arriver dans
le truc énorme qui était dans un bon
bateau manque de bajil pardon c'est pas
le bon c'est pas le bon set à côté on
repart avec des 4,9
je prends le ponton et la loi que c'est
que des zodiac est hélas jeu et au japon
et je me retourne les fils étaient
barrées
[Musique]